hey everyone welcome to the lobby it's
gamespot's weekly talk show about video
games and well anything we find
interesting i'm joined today by Scott
Butterworth and Rob Hanley it's good to
see you guys we are all super super busy
it's gonna be kind of a short show today
ah lung cos were busy and too because
there's only so many things we can talk
about everything's in our embargo kind
of tight lipped yeah review season that
new thing that happens it is upon us
right yeah yeah actually happened like
everybody else is traveling so it's it's
basically the three of us I know yeah
mike is out of sorts of doing a thing
but he'll be back later today for next
week but yeah you guys are stuck with me
today i want to kick things off we're
going to talk about call of duty 4
modern warfare remastered which is
included with a few different bundles
for call duty infinite warfare and you
guys had a chance to play it recently I
don't play a lot of call of duty as much
as I love the campaign's I actually
really wasn't into it back then how does
it feel to revisit this game after what
is it six years 7999 years yeah yeah
that's funny it's I was joking about
this with John Luke yesterday that we've
had a couple of remasters come out a
year ahead of their 10-year anniversary
when it was kinda it would I don't know
if it would make more sense but it would
feel more like a culmination right but
Bioshock is the same way that came out
nine years instead of ten years whatever
um yeah you know playing playing that on
stream yesterday was it's crazy every
mission is like oh my god this mission
this mission is so great every time we
got something news okay all this thing
happens yeah it's so good so it sticks
with you after all those years for a
serious load a lot of games too yeah
well I mean a ton of games but I mean
really that first modern warfare was it
set the template for basically
everything that's happening call of duty
since then with the exception of like
maybe the black ops games just really
kind of found their own voice and did
their own thing but at least in terms of
the modern warfare trilogy and even the
games that have happened since then like
ghosts and I would assume to some extent
infinite warfare everything everything
about those games was really established
right away in modern warfare so it's
crazy to go back and play it and see
just how fully realized that whole
vision was just right out of the gate
how much of like the pacing and the
set-piece driven this of it like all
these different ideas were there from
the very beginning it's so cool what
about Rob for you like mechanically does
this game still feel like up to par with
what we've had you know
since I was you know I only played like
a good hour and a half and I was kind of
going back and forth uh personally I
just wanted to get that all ghillied up
mission the sniping one as I remember
like having such great memories of that
but you totally hit the nail on the head
of like there was one the mission i
played was where there's an Abrams tank
that's like stranded in the middle of an
area yeah you know talking about it we
have to basically go rescue rescue it
and man it was the weirdest flashback of
like hugging a corner and not even
getting to that open area but you know
what to be there I remember you having
played that like so many times like just
that was burned in my head was how hard
it was I must have played on difficulty
because I kind of flew right what um yet
that was really kind of cool I remember
just like out loud saying like oh I
remember this like I'm hugging the
corner like same thing I'm shame stalked
do we got we got to one part in the
mission yesterday and we as we were
running quarter were both like wait a
min i know it's about to happen and then
sure enough we turn the corner and
there's this TV station which we both
membered is having infinitely spawning
enemies and being just impossible to get
through and even in chatter was like oh
yeah the building sucks we had this far
the game but like before we actually got
there were like wait this seems familiar
there it is like i was yeah just like so
many of those moments it's great but as
far as and again like touching back when
i was trying to say was like fighting
whether or not i would play this like it
felt like i was playing it more for
nostalgia sake okay like trying to
imagine how impactful this game truly
was at that time however i was not it
felt very Arkady right like it was very
much like the animations of AI a on
general was pretty poor they're just
standing there shooting at you you know
there's the sometimes I like to imagine
you know called UT game to her time have
got more realistic to an extent yeah
this just felt again very Arkady I felt
like I was standing up you know with
like a plastic toy like shooting at guys
like in waves and like the structure of
certain areas was like okay now it's
this type of layout now they're gonna
come in waves or it just kind of felt
like I was fighting myself on whether i
was actually enjoying it or whether i
was like playing a memory mom but I will
say that visually
pretty up to par like you know textures
a revamped it looks it looks pretty good
i'd say there's like a lack of shadows
here and there or it's like very obvious
connections of you know polygons you're
like just walls like okay like that
looks a little weird but in general I
know it's fun it's fun to see black
captain price again yeah and here like
him bark around a team and go through
houses and stuff there were a lot of
cool moments that I yeah you just it
again yeah I just feel like it's just a
nostalgia thing where it's like oh
that's cool i remember this okay so on
that point then right so this is part of
a series of bundles that you can buy
infinite warfare so how does that sit
with you guys is that like maybe a good
way to entice people that love a series
to to continue loving it and maybe pay a
little bit more money you know just for
a dressed-up version of an old game or
is this kind of just an afterthought
that you guys were happy to play with
but you might not go back to um i would
necessarily call it an afterthought i
feel like they did a good job with the
roomies for you like isn't afterthought
for you at this point you played it a
little bit and now you got infinite
warfare coming right do you feel like
you know you've enjoyed this somewhat it
sounds like do you want to keep playing
it or are you kind of satisfied to get
that just that taste i mean i actually
might go back and beating the campaign's
not super long it's like what eight
eight hours maybe like you can actually
beat it in you no one really good
sitting or if you want if you really
want to grind through on veteran it'll
take you a little longer but honestly
just put it on normal let it kind of
sweep you up i mean i think rob was was
very right that it isn't the most
challenging game in a lot of ways the AI
is pretty predictable most of the
scenarios are kind of like easy to read
but really what makes it fun is you just
kind of get swept up in the chaos of all
of it i mean remember the time it was
really unusual to have so much happening
around you in any given mission right i
mean every mission you were immersed in
some larger battle which you were only
one small part and that you know the
cinematics and like everything about it
that made it feels so immersive that was
what was cool about it so yeah i mean
they've never been the most challenging
games but they're really easy to get
swept up in so i personally would
probably go back and play a little more
and and beat the campaign especially
since its you know relatively short and
i mean i remember really enjoying the
multiplayer at the time as well so that
i might not stick with quite as long it
depends i mean i'd have to jump in and
play it
so we haven't had a chance to play the
remastered multiplayer yet so hard to
say but i don't know and i think that
the audience that cares about modern
warfare remaster isn't necessarily the
audience that cares about infinite
warfare i think that a lot of that
goodwill has kind of burned away over
the years and call judy absolutely has
its kind of core audience that buys the
game every every single year but sort of
the longtime fans are people who been
playing into a really long time a lot of
those people tend to be kind of down on
call of duty because it's an annualized
release and they might care more about
the nostalgia of replaying that first
really truly great game versus you know
playing the next iteration of this
franchise it's now been running for such
a long time and has had has seen at
least one release I think every single
year for the almost a decade but their
only option now is to buy infinite
warfare in order to access which is the
unfortunate rub for a lot of people i
think yeah internally talking about can
you remind me what the package there are
are three different ones let me see here
we've got there's like a deluxe edition
um the legacy okay legacy digital deluxe
our legacy pro edition of infinite
warfare yeah and you have pre-purchased
not just pre-ordered oh really you have
to give activision actual money Wow and
then you will be able to play the game
and that's starting tomorrow you will be
able to download modern warfare although
you can also like wait and buy infinite
worker on disk and then use the fist but
the the disk has to remain in the system
play modern warfare so you can't just
like by the game download modern warfare
and you know sell your copy of infinite
warfare to gamestop or anything like
that do you think you would be just as
enjoyable just to go back and play the
original release of this game or does it
does it need the new sort of gussied up
HD visuals that's a good question I mean
this is something we've talked about on
about several remasters that I sort of
feel like our memories of how games
looked aren't necessarily accurate i
think we remember things look better
than they actually did and playing again
on the stream yesterday it looks it
looks very good it looks like a game
that could have come out to three years
ago I supposed to nine years ago sure it
on a different console generation so I
think that this this is kind of the way
to place ready now that I've sat down
and played a couple hours I don't know
that I could ever go back to the
original I mean I think we're probably
still working on a side-by-side visual
comparison
that'll give us a little more to work
from but yeah i would i would recommend
that you know if you really really want
to play the the the campaign again
probably worth playing the remaster if
you can i think it'd be the better
version that's a super good question cuz
like what i was getting the most out of
it was that nostalgic trip hmm it's like
why not just play the original game hmm
why not rob why not is exactly right ah
yeah yeah it mean it does look pretty
good again it's like you're just
fighting like for me I was just kind of
fighting my opinions of looks like oh I
guess this hi res explosion looks kind
of good like oh that's it kind of looks
good it looks like oh look looks good I
don't know I was going back and forth
but I was enjoying that trip is cool
alright remembering that game yeah yeah
alright well those are our impressions
of call duty 4 modern warfare remastered
which you can get if you buy one of the
deluxe editions of the upcoming infinite
warfare that's a lot of duties and
infinite Warfare's if you're interested
in this game let us know in the comments
below and do you think that remasters
are a good source of revenue or your
time down the road alright guys out last
two demo just came out Rob you had a
chance to play it do you love horror
games a lot I'm not sure that I ever see
you playing them no I mean yeah back and
forth I guess give Rob reacting to the
resident evil slim yeah yeah cuz that
was fin and I heard you had a similar
experience of that last two ah yeah
alright so describe this demo I
understand it's pretty short and this is
coming from a game that was supposed to
come out this year but was delayed until
2017 a little while ago what was it you
actually played what was available uh it
just kind of kicked off and you're just
it man it's it's funny to have played
recently that resident evil demo because
they remind me very much at the same
thing where it's like a very much on and
maybe even more so this one it felt very
much on Rails except for certain areas
but anyways you're just this guy
immediately your glasses fall off you
trip I think you're in a plane crash or
something like that and you are on a
clearly a bizarre farm where there's
some mentally ill people who like to
kill people
get out get out immediately you're just
kind of introduced to them and you are
going through areas again I haven't
really like seen any of the videos or
that demo so this was a fresh for me but
you go into an area it's like super dark
where it's a bed or a barn cradle
looking bed and there's a lot of blood
there you go oh this is what a baby
might be and there's blood not a good
sign turn the corner and there's a pit
of dead children ah so that was
surprising I don't know in general it I
could see where maybe it got delayed in
that like I couldn't I know I got a good
understanding of the game okay um in
that if it was on real like the first
half of it was like super on Rails like
you are Linear's miss lady excuse me
yeah and you're literally being directed
the entire time so you'd like turned a
corner as a guy there with an axe it's
like oh I shouldn't go that way join me
for some like that that just felt a
little old and I don't know the moments
I prefer for my horror games sometimes
is just like me having direct control of
my circumstance like there's this part
where you hid the corn fields which is
actually pretty cool there's a bunch of
people with flashlights and you're just
like you know turning your infrared
camera off and on and you're just like
avoiding them that's pretty neat I mean
that's me controlling my outcome those
were more of the tense moments that I
wish there are more of I guess I could
say yeah when it gets more open-ended
like that it's a lot less predictable
and you you and you feel like you have a
little bit more control of your destiny
so when something does go wrong it's
kind of your own fault status to jump
scare at that point right and i can say
that i do get affected by jump scares
and then this one definitely got me
there's this scene in a hallway yeah you
like go through a memory it's a bizarre
game like you to trip out I don't you
understand yeah so I explained the same
demo at PAX I think it's I think it's a
bit of an older demo that's just now
publicly available but yeah it's like
there's no real explanation for how this
happens but basically one moment you're
on a farm then you kind of crawl
a whole or fall down a hole and all of a
sudden you're like in an elementary
school that's never happened you in real
life we're not recently okay um and then
yeah you're kind of making your way
through the holiday elementary school
and like looking through lockers you'll
see like flashes of you know silhouettes
in classrooms and you kind of feel like
there's something near you or behind you
but you can never actually pin it down
and a copy of a call duty game I
remember this and eventually you leave
the school somehow I can't remember how
you get out of school I think you're
like pulled through the ceiling by
something you are literally ripped out
of your bone memory so you like I guess
the idea is that you were just like I
would imagine like tripping out
something and then you end up back on
the farm but I know I kind of like games
that will mess with though it's not
fourth wall breaking but they're very
much toying with the medium in a way
it's like well this couldn't happen in
reality but all we have to do in a game
is like when you walk in the next room
it's suddenly a totally different
environment it's so easy to execute but
so unsettling for you as a player like I
appreciate games that are willing to
sort of mess with your head like that
and use that to throw you off and keep
you creeped out that to me is a cool
approaching horror games i really like
when games do that well so nothing else
yet this particular demo had a great
sense of atmosphere although I agree
that mechanically that I was also
feeling a little bit lost um yeah like I
could have used more dead ends you know
like just dead and opening a door like
you know going around like all right
that can't open this door like oh I
can't open this door but clearly this is
the only door like I can open that go
through so this is supposed you know
this is where I'm supposed to go and I
think that just got a little tired and I
wanted more of like an exploration value
cuz that's how like Oh whenever I think
of horror movies that's how it kind of
always is it's just someone alone lost
searching like yeah and you're being
chased there's no sign telling them to
go one way or another own or did you
know yeah I mean they basically have to
figure what the hell to do yeah I'm not
opposed to that but I think you know
that they're there could be more of a
the right reason later when this when
this looks like the first like minutes
or a few minutes of that game it's just
one path layup here's a fence here's a
bunch of [ __ ] in the middle of the road
that you can't get through like that
just like alright well just yeah
hold my ang where am I going talk to me
about the the battery because I
understand you have to collect you know
power for your camera you can use the
infrared light did you find that in this
demo that that actually like had a
meaningful No are you experienced now no
my batteries never I mean oh my better
right now when I got to the the field so
I [ __ ] yeah but there was actually found
one lying in the middle of the cornfield
for some reason which is an odd place
for a better games man there are also
double A's yeah I guess I'm not sure
never takes but it happened to be the
exact battery my camera needed to it
worked out uh yeah I don't know I think
I also was like rushing it but that's
kind of how I feel like a [ __ ] game
should you know you mean like you're not
like I'm gonna explore yeah while i'm
being chased like there's reasons for
that uh that I felt like we're untouched
more or less I don't know also having
played resident evil 7 in VR yeah is
this the sort of experience that you
imagine might also translate well mmhmm
yeah yeah absolutely although with that
in mind in the residence 7 do they have
like a camcorder anything that they were
like using no nothing yeah just on your
own yeah i think this totally would work
is that yeah those two were very similar
yeah um I could totally see we are being
great for this I'm sure if it was on
PlayStation VR they could just use the
controller as to mimic a camera you just
hold it up that's what getting act like
how how do you account for one another
VR yeah I don't know I enjoyed it for
the most part I don't know um I wonder
you're like why I was delayed because
that this kind of left me like
questioned like what is the this level
design structure of this like I felt
kind of like off like well you know it's
one thing to consider like the legacy
the last game which was kind of a
surprise success it sounded like four
red big red barrels the developer they
were almost taken aback by it and so
that spurred them to continue to make
this series you can imagine that they
really want to nail it otherwise they
stand to maybe lose all of that goodwill
that they've earned so this demo might
be just a good way for them to sort of
put something out there for people who
were expecting the game but won't get it
until next year right yeah and that's
definitely what I think the takeaway is
is like you know you enjoy it for what
it is get get hyped also the ending was
a little weird
you got the ending I don't know the
ending do I want to know should we spoil
is I mean it's a demo demo so not breed
me what happens uh you run into one of
the fantastic farmers and he takes an
axe to your crotch my crotch yet
specifically you were in the game so
that in VR would be super fun gosh yeah
gianluca me into that we were discussing
this yesterday yo shoots with the crush
that guy all rights a lot more about
jean-luc than we really wanted to know
oh yeah absolutely yeah all right that's
the outlast to demo did you guys get a
chance to plant let us know in the
comments below and are you still looking
forward to the game despite its
linearity gentlemen that's pretty much
all the new stuff we can talk about
because we don't have mafia 3 yeah the
game is coming out in just a couple of
days and typically at this point we
would have a review out the name of the
game this time around like it was with
doom is that no copies are coming out
until release day that can often ring
alarm bells for some people hmm but
who's to really say cuz doom turned out
really well um Scott you're gonna be the
one reviewing this game I am and you
have the unfortunate duty of doing it
you know with without maybe a finish
line in mind yeah but you know in your
mind is this really a bad sign that this
game is coming out late I mean have you
had a chance to play any of it at events
thus far only once in a very limited
capacity so it's really not enough to
like color my perception of the game I
mean I I love what they're doing
thematically I'm excited about the
setting I'm excited characters I like
that they've gone could have committed
to a fully open world game so there are
a lot of reasons I think it might be
really great yeah sometimes if you don't
get review copies ahead of a game's
launch that can be a sign that you know
there-there's something to hide and you
know the publisher doesn't have faith in
the product and therefore they don't
want people reading reviews but that's
also totally not necessarily the case I
mean doom is a great example as you just
pointed out of a game that was actually
really great and that again we just
didn't get until like day of if not like
you may have actually I think went out
and bought a copy from what i remember
we used an australian PSN account to
download it ya know i think the one
thing to consider here you know you
bring up this sort of the themes in this
game
name which deal a lot with race during a
time in America's history was super
tumultuous and it begs the question
maybe they're scared of people reading
reactions to that you know the marketing
behind this game has been pretty
consistent and loud for a long time now
and it's almost like that they'd rather
have the marketing speak for the game
then other people sort of impart their
opinion on how they're handling
something so potentially caustic right
now I mean it's it's one thing if they
they're really confident that they've
nailed it but how can you be confident
about speaking about something so
controversial especially this year when
things that kind of hit the fan in a way
just a little um I mean it's entirely
possible that they don't want
controversy to eclipse the game itself
yeah that is a very interesting theory I
mean honestly who's to say that's
something we'd have to talk to the
publishers and developers about but that
is entirely possible because you're very
right this game is approaching some very
difficult subject matter or some stuff
that has sort of proven to be touchy
especially among gamers and yet to sort
of broach those topics in a serious way
in a way that's not gonna be comfortable
for a lot of people naturally that's
going to become a focus for certain
crowds for certain audiences and there
is definitely a chance that the noise or
the reaction that comes from that will
overshadow the game itself so wanted to
avoid that makes a lot of sense I have
no idea if that's what's happening but
there's a lot of weight behind that
theory like that that makes a great deal
of sense yeah I mean it's very difficult
to say but this game has been in
development for a while and we've seen
it in quite its finished form you know
for some time right we've had recent
events where people had to play a large
chunk of the game so it really does beg
the question where are these copies and
this is not as tail of us being sad that
we don't get to play the game will get
to play it eventually like a lot of
people but in a sense reviews kind of do
a service for the consumer right yeah
because pre-orders are such a thing in
video games now where people feel
compelled to get the game on day one and
there you know stoked with like pre
order items and all these other
exclusives that reviews are sort of the
only line of defense in some ways to
protect people from when a game really
isn't as good as the companies claiming
it to be so I think that is actually the
bigger problem here so I don't want
people to think that we're whining that
like oh we don't get to play the game
yet and our job is that difficult but
it's actually a concern for everybody
because a lot of people put down six
bucks without much beyond an
advertisement here or video there yeah
and lower key I mean I will say that if
people are concerned if if you heard
this news and you thought like they have
something to hide clear this game is
gonna you know be awful and they've been
lying this all this time like if that
was your reaction then wait like we are
going to review the game we are
absolutely going to review it it'll our
review will probably go up sometime next
week we're going to get it done as
efficiently as we can obviously as our
other outlets so I mean if if people out
there actually concerned if they if they
need a review to validate an opinion or
if they want to be certain that they're
buying something that's gonna be worth
their money give it a couple days like
you're you're you're not wrong that
pre-orders are pushed more and more and
that has totally become a thing and you
know maybe the people who preordered are
confident that they're gonna love it no
matter what but if you haven't
pre-ordered and if you are concerned
just wait don't buy it they won like
yeah read reviews uh wait and hear what
your friends think you know watch
youtubers play it I guarantee this
committee 10 people streaming on twitch
like make up your mind you can you can
gather information from so many sources
these days that you know if it turns out
the game is terrible and it isn't worth
your money you will know you figure that
out so like I don't know I I don't
interpret this as like you know
necessarily a bad sign I don't think
that it's necessarily you know like the
developers the publisher trying to lie
to their audience or something right I
think it's just like they made a
strategic choice and that's their right
because it's their products like we are
not know Scott you know we don't deserve
I did look I'm with you one hundred
percent I'm preaching the choir I'm
saying this is bad for the I'm not
saying this means the game is bad no no
but I think people sometimes make that
assumption I have seen that in comment
section right no I just want to be clear
that like this is not saying that they
have something necessarily to hide like
a bad German people are going to feel
duped but at the same time it is highly
unusual behavior right that only occurs
a few times a year with very specific
games with doom there's really no we
don't know why yeah there I we never
really got an explanation why and it
turned out that hey everything was fine
with mafia you know who really knows
like this game I think yeah I just
worried that it's about the controversy
I worry that that is the reason again I
have no freakin knowledge yeah i'm sure
there's like a day one patch that they
want to like you know tidy everything up
like so many big games but
so many those big games we also get
ahead of time on those damn one patches
sure they may make a difference but they
don't really impact the entire game at
large it's really something that like
please the developer in a way right the
creator's behind it so I'm a little
disappointed that I guess that they're
not willing to put their a confident
foot forward and give this out and
that's how I feel about it that's fair
yeah all right well mafia 3 is coming
out soon we will have a review are you
looking forward to the game I think
everyone should give it a shot just
because of the things that's tackling
it's really rare we get these subject
matters in games but let us know how you
feel in the comments below following
mafia three there are so many other
games coming on to the 16 and I know the
ones i'm excited for primarily Last
Guardian I am super curious how the lane
is gonna turn out after a decade I don't
think it's gonna I don't know that it's
going to be amazing but I know that I'm
just endlessly curious Final Fantasy 15
as well but what about you guys what's
the stuff you're looking forward to the
rest of the year um I'm curious to see
what battlefield is like and as well as
titanfall I'm actually super excited to
play that campaign having like seen
snippets of it I'm sure you got you saw
some of it it looks great looks like
it's just it feels like a perfect
example of a developer that saw all the
feedback and was like okay we'll just do
that we'll take all the feedback on like
and there was much of a story I didn't
understand like it they hit every like
they hit every mark with developing that
like Titan pilot relationship that just
seems so strong and then some of the
footage we've seen looks real like I'm
really excited for that and to know more
about that universe because it's a sweet
universe but that campaign we just did
invite me a hard time of you know
intertwining that with multiplayer like
you're just so distracted so yeah this
that's I think that's really exciting
but unfortunately that those are
basically the same what two weeks one
week the battlefield in time for the
pretty close yeah not far both both due
out this month this month particular is
really intense but yeah I mean I
actually got to play a few hours at two
or two or three hours of titan falls
campaign and and yeah I mean I the year
your perception is is very right they
dug into the story they really fleshed
out the relationship between one
particular pilot and Titan actually I
think that the most surprising thing
about my time with the single player was
the fact that you have dialogue options
yeah constantly your bantering with your
Titan BTW or just either over the radio
or like while you're piloting him and
like he just kind of ways in with stuff
like as you're moving to level and you
can choose how you respond you can be
kind of snarky or you can like be nice
about things and it doesn't really
direct the story in any way it's just
kind of allowing you to shape that
friendship or that partnership in a way
that that reflects kind of your
personality you know I thought that was
kind of a cool choice this is gun in
there for some flavor it just keeps you
engaged actly actually am I in my am i
right about the Sinclair I compared it
to fire watch which is the closest thing
I could think of that it's not so much
about you know you unlock a different
ending if you direct the narrative down
this path it's just you were kind of
shaping a relationship which is really
cool I think they actually have done a
pretty good job with that that portion
of the writing was really good and also
and from what I saw as well was you know
taking different directions of like are
you more into the humor side of a story
to be told yeah choose that path or you
want to know maybe you want to know more
specifics or more more details it seem
like they're kind of directing those
choices in that direction yeah I don't
think it runs super deep but you
definitely have some degree of control
over how you engage the world for sure
yeah um so I'm I'm pretty psyched about
the campaign and actually I've really
enjoyed multiplayer as well I know
people weren't weren't super stoked on
the beta but I've now also played like
the full competitive suite with all of
the titans in it and a whole bunch of
new maps and modes and stuff and it all
kind of comes together in an interesting
way Rob and I have talked about this
before so honestly I'm pretty psyched
about titanfall I know people are a
little cold on it after having played
the beta but I'm I'm site I having now
played quite a bit of it I'm very
excited same thing with gears actually
played a lot of gears I think that's
coming together really well I really
like the direction the team is taking it
seems like they have a firm
understanding of the franchise and know
when to defer to the legacy of the game
and went to kind of push things in a new
direction I had a lot of fun playing the
campaign it felt very much like a gears
campaign of like you know this
mix of very linear corridor shooting
that then opens up into a broader arena
and then like you are you counter a
set-piece moment and everything is paced
very deliberately and it's very
cinematic and you get these you know
relationship moments between the
characters it's all very very gears and
seem to be pretty well executed at least
a portion that I play it and then
multiplayers well drawing a lot from
gears past but doing new things with it
like super fun I much to do in a stream
of horde mode tomorrow so people want to
tune in horde mode is a ton of fun i
really like what they've done with that
so gears is like god i think it comes
out next week right cheese yeah that's
coming up so i'm i'm psyched for gears
i'm hoping it's going to be as good as
the portions that i've played so far
about watch dogs to rob you grew up in
San Francisco does that appeal to you at
all playing a game like that's supposed
to be realized the city like that well
and by such depth yeah you know I look I
looked at some of the absolutely like I
would definitely see some of the
landmarks like the bush guy Oh is he in
the he is and supposedly unfortunately
he actually died in real life or here I
know yeah so people who don't know the
bush guy is person down by the pier who
would hide behind a swath of bush and
jump out and scare unsuspecting tourists
much to the delight of everyone else but
those tourists yeah and did this for
years Oh years yep he's great he's in
the game which i think is great look up
on youtube yeah you know I think it's
it's cool you know the you know they got
an office out here like I think they're
gonna do the city justice I think
they're gonna show it well my main
concern and I think it looks like they
really stepped it up was for me watch
dogs one I got unfortunately like three
hours in yeah and literally lost a
craving battle for GTA like literally
will it put that game down and would
like play GTA 5 because that open world
for me and then driving and you just I
feel like it was just not clicking like
it wasn't believable the open world
people walking around chatting like it
just like nothing sold me as well as
like I kinda thought oh game however
this time around it looked like they've
really gone into the direction of like
you know what we're just gonna give you
all these great abilities like you know
you could basically frame a police
officer on the
street and say he's a wanted murderer
and all the cops will turn their guns on
him like I feel like they were done a
nice job of just like giving you all the
tools to like have fun but not
necessarily saying like this was great
you knowing me like not taking the route
of say like a Saints Row where it's like
overly just like sarcastic almost I
don't know right and this just seems a
much more enjoyable world to display in
it looks good the footage looks good I'm
I got my hopes for that she seems fun
like neptr what was missing from the
first game it was so like even the hero
is just this dour humorless jerk who is
just I mean in a sense in the story
context is he lost it family and there's
this redemption story but the entire
game felt so gray and self serious that
it really was just kind of missing fun
and so I feel like this this new world
in this new city and you set a new
character all kind of have at least a
degree of fun to it that makes you kind
of want to spend time there i'm a little
worried that they're gonna go too over
the top with like the millennial
flavoring and like runs gonna be way too
much slang that doesn't quite make sense
again so i'm a little concerned that
that's going to be kind of grading but
outside of that i'm way more excited
about this world and even this game as a
whole than i was about the original
watchdogs the other thing i would i
would add to what rob was saying and I
agree with everything he said I really
appreciated they made hacking so much
more open it felt like it was you know
you were very dependent on your
environment everything was you know if
you happen to be standing near a
particular thing that's what you could
hack that's right use but if you weren't
near anything hackable you were just you
were screwed like you said no options in
this game you have like a drone that you
can deploy a couple different drums you
can deploy seems like there's more stuff
you can hack in more stuff you can do
when you hack it is it gives you a lot
more freedom and makes that mechanic
kind of more useful and and something
that will actually make the game feel
distinctive as opposed to just being
this thing that's like shoehorned in
like ah look where a hacker game yeah no
not really it's such a good point just
like that was the problem with the first
one was it was very much one-off hacking
abilities yeah like everything was
contextual roadblock in the middle of
the street now it seems like you can do
a lot of combinations with different
hacking abilities like you said the
drone like I can get to you know
somewhere that would
not be possible for me to do on foot
right get here easier I can combo I mean
yeah you know frame this cop while I
thought wire his car like Freeman cops
huh I'm so dumb i'm great just like no
it's hilarious we we went to the police
academy together i thought i knew this
guy uh you know just situations uh just
seems funny what was the other you can
also uh inform like the like a local
gang that like this person you know
frame some like a 1 i'm just gonna frame
everyone inside play that game is your
subject so funny about that never hijack
a car never to just go around like
ruining people's lives misinformation
this is a funny thing of people like
some gang guy on his phone like oh [ __ ]
so it's all took a bunch of coke like on
his phone constantly will just then go
to that person and kill him or like
started all seen the mill the street
like just standing there goodness sounds
so funny i just real it'll be really
interesting to compare watchdogs and
mafia cuz those are sort of the two big
open world third person and story-driven
like they're very similar at least on
paper I mean thematically in the story
they're trying to tell very very
different but like mechanically in terms
of the game they're trying to be very
similar so I think that'll be an
interesting showdown this holiday season
I know I'm super curious about both
games like how gunplay and like actions
gonna play into it all because it seems
like I they're playing with really cool
concepts and themes but then it's like
this de facto sort of like actions stuff
thrown into like satisfy part of the
audience that's one goes there whole
games gonna fall apart I mean that's
okay that we struggle for GTA four years
right yeah I can like yeah I can crack
that shiny veneer in such a way that's
like oh you know it stands out like a
sore thumb totally I guess we'll find
out only is there any other games you
guys are looking forward to I mean
there's there's honestly a lot coming
give me one more civ I'm excited I've
got a big civilization van for a very
long time I'm really excited about the
changes they made in civ kind of like
with gears I appreciate just the
direction they're taking it the ideas
that they've tried to imbue in this in
this new iteration just like unstacking
the cities and the hidden agendas all
these different mechanics that have now
been layered on top that are gonna I
hope and I think infest according to
Mike my hearty are going
change the way that the game plays in a
kind of fundamental way without totally
altering the the franchise's DNA right
um so I'm excited to see how that pans
out I have a lot of faith in that team
they clearly know what they're doing so
I'm excited for more civ and I'm excited
that it's something a little different
it's not just like a blockbuster shooter
which seems to be a big you know chunk
of the games to come out at this time of
year so that could be a really cool
break from some of the other stuff we're
getting this county season there's a lot
of shoot-'em-ups coming out yeah there
are yeah lots of guns as every year yeah
i will say that i will definitely play
uh infinite warfare campaign like that
it looks pretty good yeah dude space dog
fighting it was fun I'll try that I hope
that works oh it's worth I an ulti I'll
try it yeah the hell I want it to be
good that's a good point like man if I
want by God but I want dog fighting I
want one to one I want me controlling my
own roles if it's like super on Rails
just like hold the trigger down and just
fire away like give me back get me out
of here give me on foot [ __ ] what
are you gonna hack enemy ships and tell
them about all those coke deals I want
to frame someone Peter what has you so
excited about a Last Guardian that's so
interesting hear you say that because I
feel like that has fallen off of a lot
of people's radars like it was it's been
in development for so long now that we
finally seen any people are kind of like
yeah whatever and it seems like it's
moment is kind of past but apparently
not for you so why are you still psyched
about it moments don't pass for me when
it comes to games that I haven't had a
chance to play and no this is something
that you know seriously was announced
back win Fumito away de the developer of
eco shadow the Colossus now this was at
the peak of his career and this seemed
to be the next step in his evolution as
a developer to dramatize the whole thing
his final floor yes and so we know we've
we've seen people play the game and
we've seen their reactions and it sounds
kind of middling but a lot of things
they describe our sort of part and
parcel of shadow of the colossus and the
way it controls the way to animates and
I'm okay with that hmm I do think it may
stand out in today's modern era where
things are maybe a little bit more tight
unless you know floaty but again that's
a style that I'm I've accepted in the
past and I maybe I embrace older games
more than most folks but I do think that
there's a chance that
that won't ruin the game for me so I put
that aside and what I'm left with is my
initial sense of wonder at what can you
wait us on do to really surprise me
again and I just don't know and so that
is why I'm so interested in seeing it
there are ads on buses now that game is
frickin coming out so it's coming so I
feel like I'm ready to actually be
excited to be curious and I'm a little
sad that it comes at the tail end of the
season though because I think people are
going to be so exhausted please don are
in from so many games and even for
consumers if probably spent a lot of
money up until that point yeah and I
think a similar fate is something that
fallen fantasy 15 faces another game
it's been development for a long time
though this one has changed hands and it
seems to be coming together it's evolved
a lot since the the two demos that we've
had a chance to play but you know final
fantasy as much as I love it it can
excuse me for saying it can be too far
up its own but sometimes to the point
here it you know it loses maybe sight of
the things that the audience really
loves and it's sort of trying to tell
the audience what they should love a lot
of games fault you know have that
problem but final fantasy 13 exhibited
those issues quite a bit now again
development is sort of changed hands and
this is not the same team that made 13
by any measure but you know there's been
some things like this sort of like that
the top-heavy girl whose shirt is
unbuttoned right that's the sort of
thing where it's like that shouldn't be
important to either emphasize or defend
and if that's the thing they're going to
stick with plus all these like fashion
things tacked on top of it I wonder
where their priorities are hmm so I'm
glad to see that it's improved I'm
cautious to see that it's doing some
things that don't really matter to me
and I think a lot of people and so
company again you combine those two
things and it's like what will this be
what can it turn out to be and while the
pleasure of finding out in a November I
guess fingers crossed yeah this stage it
is interesting that those are both come
in a little later on I know but at least
nice thing i would i would say about you
a disans games as they tend to be kind
of timeless so you know people miss it
you know this December I've like that
kind of experience has has legs and and
could still be something beautiful and
enjoyable assuming the game come came
together yeah you know just as much next
year's would be this year so hopefully
as it should be right yeah yeah and so
hopefully doesn't get completely over
but even if it does to some extent I
think that that will you know as with
shadow the classes become you know at
least find a cult following if nothing
else all right those are the games we
are looking forward to throughout the
rest of the year let us know what you
are looking forward to in the comments
below gentlemen that was a lobby it was
short it was bite-sized yeah it's one of
those weeks we've got a lot of stuff
coming out of the pipe next week yeah
finally talk about some things tomorrow
PlayStation VR related which I'm super
excited about oh yeah we're gonna stream
in my house be fun yeah we are going to
eleven o'clock I think excited hour and
a half and then o Geer stream later in
the day have you seen later any day yeah
a lot of streaming going on a lot of
good games coming out well hopefully
good games yeah we'll see about that
marketing got to me haha just optimistic
i appreciate that Peter yeah you know
why not it's when i get to review the
game that's when i get to actually put
my credit card on but for now I like to
just you know we'll have fun for I think
I think we all want games to be good I
always want you I always rooting idea
try to mark that as well because it's
like who wants a bad game and I and I
don't think that's an obvious thing I
don't think something to take for
granted like I I appreciate people that
have that attitude that like listen I
want everything to be great i wanted
room and have fun people spend a lot of
time and effort on these things like i
don't know video games yeah video games
yeah and watch them here we can watch
you can watch this chat about them every
Tuesday 2 p.m. pacific on the lobby
thanks for joining everyone take care
see you next time